سواد نعمه المدينه لذيذ لا نور لا كهرباء
ولا اشارات ضوئيه بعد استهدافها بموجه
جديده من الصواريخ الروسيه اضطربت على
اثرها محطات الكهربائي وتراكم الضغط على
البنيه التحتيه الحيويه فضلا عن انخفاض
درجات الحراره الى ما دون الصفر لتتضاعف
معاناه السكان بالتزامن مع حلول موسم
الشتاء القارس
لكن يمكنك بالتاكيد التكيف لدينا مصابيح
كهربائيه وشاح الطاقه كل ما تحتاجه لتشعر
بالراحه في هذه الاوضاع انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي طال جميع المناطق الاوكرانيه
بعد ما تسبب القصف الروسي بتطبيق نظام
الاغلاق الطارئ لتحقيق الاستقرار في شبكه
الامداد
موسكو حملت اوكرانيا مسؤوليه الاستهدافات
الروسيه للمواقع الاوكرانيه بعد ما نفذت
الاخرى هجمات بطائره مسيره تسببت في تفجير
قاعدتين جويتين ومقتل ثلاثه جنود
روسلانسكي خرج في رد على الروس ليقول
شعبنا لا يستسلموا ابدا مشيرا الى ان
بلاده اسقطت غالبيه الصواريخ الروسيه وبدا
المهندسون بالفعل العمل على اعاده
الكهرباء
نور يستحق السماء
لثواني الا وظلام يعقبه لايام صواريخ
الروسيه لا تزال تستهدف اوكرانيا وسط
التزايد المطالب الدوليه
لايجاد حلول تحول بين الخطوات العسكريه
والمدنيين امل الرويشد العربيه